Il y a quelques temps, j'avais fait une vidéo
sur les techniques de drague,
où j'expliquais que je galérais
un peu avec les meufs.
Mais bon, ça,
c'était avant.
Faux !
Quand t'échanges des textos pour la première fois
avec une meuf, tu sais très bien si tu lui plais ou pas.
Tu sais, ça se voit
juste avec les smileys.
Si elle fait un smiley cœur,
c'est qu'elle est à fond sur toi.
Si elle fait un smiley bisou + cœur, t'as encore
un peu de taf, mais t'es sur la bonne voie.
Si elle fait un smiley bisou,
mais sans cœur, on sait pas.
Ça pourrait très bien
être un bisou amical.
Si elle fait les doigts comme ça, c'est plutôt mal parti.
Là, t'es bienvenue dans la friend zone.
Et si elle fait un immeuble
comme ça—
bon j'ai pas une explication
pour tous les smileys non plus.
Tu sais, moi, dès que je suis
en flirt avec une meuf—
Ouais, j'emploie des mots
des années 80.
♪ Pour un flirt avec toi ♪
Moi, dès que je suis en flirt avec une meuf
et qu'on échange des textos,
je me prends la tête pendant des heures,
pour écrire un texto
qui soit à la fois le texto du mec intéressé,
mais quand même un peu distant.
Peut-être que j'écris juste,
tout simple, "Oui hâte de te voir."
>> Trop sec.
"Oui, hâte de te voir." tu vois ?
>> Trop le mec dans la ponctuation.
"J'ai hâte de te voir, bisous, smiley", tu vois ?
>> Ça fait trois smileys dans la même phrase, là.
[dring] Elle a répondu.
>> Qu'est-ce qu'elle a répondu ?
Elle a mis un immeuble.
Moi, je sais pas draguer, je galère.
Pourtant, à l'inverse, les filles, elles arrivent
vraiment à me séduire avec un rien.
Excuse-moi, t'as pas du feu s'il te plaît ?
>> Ouais.
C'est hyper aguicheur, je trouve,
de cacher des trucs dans ses sous-vêtements.
Bon d'ailleurs, y a que les filles qui peuvent faire ça,
y a jamais un mec qui fait—
Tiens ! Et il reste un poil dessus.
Ouais, mais non, je crois
que j'ai plus envie de fumer, en fait.
Tu sais, moi, ça m'est déjà arrivé
de jouer un peu à la bagarre avec une fille.
Tu sais, ça rend complice,
c'est mignon.
Ha ha ha !
Par contre, si tu te fais maîtriser par la meuf,
t'as tout de suite l'air un peu moins attirant.
Attends, c'est plus marrant du tout, là !
J'ai carrément mal, là !
Ha ha ha, c'est trop mignon,
t'as pas de force.
Putain, j'ai trop mal !
Arrête !
Dans ce genre de circonstances,
moi, je sors toujours cette phrase :
Non, mais attends, mais là,
je mets pas toute ma force.
Normalement, si je mettais toute ma force,
ce serait un truc de ouf !
Sauf qu'au bout d'un moment,
tu peux plus mentir.
je voudrais pas te faire mal.
Tu vois, là, je me suis laissé faire, par exemple.
Oh putain !
C'est vrai que, pour draguer,
l'alcool, c'est pas mal.
Tu sais, ça désinhibe,
tu te sens un peu confiant.
Moi, j'aime bien, sauf quand la meuf
est beaucoup plus bourrée que moi.
Franchement, t'es trop charmante.
J'ai trop envie de t'embrasser.
Les capotes,
je trouve ça traître.
Parce que, à la fois, il faut absolument
en avoir sur soi toujours, par sécurité,
mais en même temps, si la meuf se rend compte
que t'en as une sur toi au tout début du rendez-vous,
alors que tu l'as à peinte rencontrée,
bah ça le fait pas trop.
Oh merde !
>> Ah ouais !
Attends, mais qu'est-ce que ça fait là, ça ?
C'est abusé !
Attends, mais qui a mis
une capote dans mon portefeuille ?
On peut la jeter à la poubelle,
je m'en fous moi.
Ouais !
Au pire, je la mets dans ma poche,
dans le but de la jeter plus tard.
Pff !
>> OK. C'est bon, je la jette.
Toute façon, moi, à chaque fois
que je suis dans ce genre de situation,
on voit très bien
si je mens ou pas.
OK.
>> T'as un préservatif ?
Un préservatif ? Euh, je sais pas,
peut-être, attends, je vérifie.
Ah bah, j'en ai 16
et un max de lubrifiant. Nickel !
Un jour, je me suis inscrit sur un site
de rencontres pour déconner.
Enfin pour [bip].
Et quand tu t'inscris,
tu dois préciser ta sexualité.
Alors hétéro, homo, ... et il y avait
un des choix qui était "hétéro curieux".
Je trouvais ça génial comme concept.
Hé, Norman, tu viens nous rejoindre ?
>> Ah non, moi je suis juste hétéro curieux.
Je suis juste là par curiosité.
Je prends quelques notes, allez-y !
En vrai, c'est un peu nul de draguer,
c'est un peu nul de forcer les choses.
Tu sais, y a rien de plus agréable
au monde que de séduire quelqu'un
sans faire exprès,
juste en étant soi-même.
Tu sais, en laissant
ton charme naturel faire le travail.
En tout cas, je vais être sincère avec vous,
depuis que je fais des vidéos,
je sais pas pourquoi, mais la question
que tout le monde me pose,
en particulier les journalistes,
c'est toujours :
Alors Norman, avec le succès de vos vidéos,
maintenant, avec les filles, ça se passe comment ?
Hein ? Ça doit —
Ça doit y aller.
Et quand je dis ça doit y aller, je parle pas forcément de jouer aux échecs... si vous voyez ce que je veux dire...
Bon, c'est vrai qu'avec les filles,
maintenant, c'est, disons, un peu différent.
Excuse-moi, je t'ai vu toute seule au bar
et je viens te voir parce que—
Stop ! Non, c'est pas parce que
t'es "Norman fait des vidéos"
que tu peux venir me draguer, d'accord ?
Je suis pas une groupie !
Bah, je veux juste te rendre ton foulard,
je crois que tu l'as fait tombé.
Ah ! Oh non, c'est trop mignon ,
oh merci beaucoup, c'est —
Attends, c'est pas parce que t'es "Norman fait des vidéos"
que je vais te dire merci, OK !
Putain, le mec a le melon,
mais j'hallucine !
You lose
Continue ?
Au revoir !
Yes !
C'est bon !
Oh, c'est Mamie qui m'a envoyé une petite carte
avec un petit chaton trop mignon, c'est adorable !
Y a pas de chèque ?
Y a pas de chèque !
Ben je m'en bats les couilles, alors !
Cadeau suivant !
Moi, à la base,
je suis plus Légo.